there are a lot of taiko drums in SOCOM
for yes in fact there are a lot of
specifically Asian instrumentation in
the game many of which are played by
people that watch Battlestar Galactica
you will hear a lot of these same
specialty soloists really I've come to
think of these guys and gals as my band
I was able to do a lot of the things
that I enjoy doing most combining
Western Orchestra with Eastern
instruments using Eastern soloists and a
little hint of rock and roll and to
create this really unique sound just for
the game the developers first approached
me about using a lot of gamelan if you
don't know a gamelan orchestra is a
Southeast Asian ensemble of players that
play with to the western eye they look a
lot like marimbas and xylophones they
have a really unique dreamlike hypnotic
ethereal tone working with the gamelan I
started thinking that it'd be fun to use
it in ways that we don't normally hear
it it's not necessarily peaceful and
serene it can be violent and aggressive
and we can use it in action cues and
horror cues and use it to communicate an
urgency and tension that you're not
normally hearing this ensemble play and
we actually worked with a live gamelan
we had a real players and a real room we
filled the Warner Brothers scoring stage
in Los Angeles with this gamelan and
recorded them for days until you hear
them in a room you just don't appreciate
how bizarre it is
the actual notes that the gamelan plays
are not notes that an orchestra
complaint some of them are the same and
some of them are different so I found
that trying to get the orchestra and the
gamelan to fit together sometimes was a
real challenge that combination to me is
the soul of what so come forth is that
is the identity of so confluent it's not
just there as source music it's not just
there like they're listening to the
local radio station this is a score and
it has to do all the things that a score
it needs to do it's just doing it in
another language